the show is about mentors and teachers
the show is about um
teammates
and i wouldn't be here without those
three
you know
uh things in my life yes yes yeah yeah
there it is
very very pointy i'm sure everybody says
that but it really is okay jason that
moment they open the envelope and right
before they say your name what goes
through your head and then when you hear
your name
yeah i mean the moment before
you know we were nominated for a few
awards right before that didn't go our
way yeah and so there's no
i mean i wasn't assuming anything on
that side too and even though we've had
a real uh and i've had a really you know
really a neat personal run of of one of
these things there was no assumption
that was like okay and then you hear ja
and you're like okay
there's a few more syllables to go and
then yeah then it was yeah it's just
yeah it's fascinating
something else look at that smile man
it's a birthday present how is this for
a birthday present
it's not bad i mean it's not bad you
know normally the best gifts are the
ones that you get from people you love
i can't say that everybody that voted
for me loves me they might really like
the show or even love the show but um so
i would put it like you know
seventh all-time greatest birthday gift
seventh
seventh all right wooden listen i think
it was the e.t hoodie that did it it
brought you the luck that's right i'm
just saying
i'll bring you another what's the next
golden globe i got you we got you i'm
going to bring you a large you got it i
might even bring them a large just in
case yeah i could wear it over the
ceiling came by here too and we told him
that you mentioned he was in the
bathroom
i want to thank lauren who went to go
take a dump now perfect how'd that go
that didn't go so well not so well diddy
not so well he was like i was i'm not
you know one's not ready for prime time
player always not ready for prime time
the birthday was yesterday got the emmy
tonight what's the turn up like tonight
i don't know i mean like
we'll see you know we got to keep things
safe and keep things you know want to
lead a little bit by example but i know
we're all staying in the same hotel so
the turnip will be real
he'll buy out the bar yeah exactly yeah
yeah cash bar apple apple that's right
apple apple pay love it thank you
congratulations
[Music]